TO WORK NEED FIREARMS TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES, OBVIOUSLY.
TODAY CONGRESSPERSON ANDY BIGGS
MADE THAT POINT.
HE WAS THEN INTERRUPTED BY HER
OWN TO GRETA THUNBERG, THE
CREEPY LITTLE PUBLICITY SEEKER
DAVID HOGG.
REMEMBER HIM?
>> ON THE PART OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS BASICALLY
SANCTIONED THIS --
[INDISTINCT]
>> REITERATING THE POINT OF
SHOOTERS, ANTI-SEMITIC,
ANTIBLACK AND RACIST.
GUESS WHAT, THOSE GUNS ARE
COMING FROM THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA!
THEY AREN'T COMING FROM MEXICO!
THEY ARE NOT COMING FROM MEXICO!
YOU ARE REITERATING THE POINT OF
A MASS SHOOTER, SIR.
SIR, YOU ARE PERPETUATING
VIOLENCE!
>> Tucker: THE LOW IQ HARVARD
STUDENT SCREAMING ABOUT RACE,
ANOTHER SELF-RIGHTEOUS CHILD WHO
HAS NO IDEA WHAT HE'S TALKING
ABOUT.
BY DAVID HOGG, APPROPRIATELY
NAMED CHARACTER, OBSTRUCTED,
TALKING ABOUT INSURRECTION.
LIZ CHENEY, ISN'T THAT A CRIME?
IS THIS INSURRECTION IS GOING TO
FACE A CRIME?
ANDY BIGGS IS THE MEMBER OF
CONGRESS WHOSE OFFICIAL BUSINESS
WAS INTERRUPTED BY THIS
INSURRECTION IS REPRESENTS A
REZONING THE U.S. CONGRESS.
CONGRESSMAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
I FOUND IT INTERESTING, PEOPLE
CAN DISAGREE WITH THE POINT YOU
WERE MAKING BUT IT WAS KIND OF A
LOGICAL ONE.
HE DIDN'T RESPONDED TO A SINGLE
POINT AND SOMETHING ABOUT
RACISM?
IS THAT WHAT IT WAS?
>> BASICALLY SAYING I AM A
TERRORIST MANIFESTO TOTING
CONSPIRACY NOT, AND THE REALITY
IS HE WANTS TO GET ON TV AND HE
WANTED TO ADVOCATE FOR A NAUGHTY
POSITION AND YOU'RE RIGHT, AS A
NUMBER OF ISSUES WERE RAISED
INTERRUPTED OUR PROCEEDING AT
DEMOCRATS A FEW INTERRUPTED
PROCEEDING THAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF INSURRECTION, AND
SO THE POLICE HAD TO TAKE HIM
OUT.
HE WAS INVITED THERE BY THE
DEMOCRATS, THAT IS WHAT I'M
INFORMED AND HE IS TRYING TO
GRAFT ON THIS WHOLE THING, IT
LOOKS LIKE.
WHERE IS THAT J SIX COMMITTEE
WHEN YOU NEED THEM?
>> Tucker: THAT KID, I KNOW A
LOT OF YOUR COLLEAGUES WENT TO
HARVARD AND A LOT OF AMERICANS
STILL THINK IT IS IMPRESSIVE.
KNOWING THAT KID WENT TO HARVARD
CAN WE ALL ADMIT IT IS KIND OF A
MEDIOCRE JOKE OR NO?
>> ABSOLUTELY, HARVARD HAS GONE
THE WAY OF ALL WOKE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS IN
THE COUNTRY.
THERE'S VERY FEW OF THEM THAT
ARE GOING TO TURN OUT SOMEBODY
THAT IS AS RADICAL AS THAT IN
STOKING THE FIRE LIKE THAT IS
WITH THE DEMOCRATS DID.
THAT IS WHY THEY WANTED THEM
THERE.
THEY WERE HOPING FOR THAT KIND
OF INCIDENT.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT KID IS
TOO DUMB TO HOST A CABLE NEWS
SHOW, AND THAT IS SAYING OR NOT.